[Music]
we were talking about [ __ ] our pants
earlier today and now we have a story I
can go with it I told my short story
yeah I got two more you got short
stories too
oh I got many short stories let me tell
you the first yeah please tell me this
one first okay so this one first well
you sound like the Godfather was that
was it tequila or Marlon Brando how come
you're so cool about taking it to kilo
shop I used your [ __ ] Atwater cuz it
doesn't taste good
all right so this guy named Colin
O'Brady became the first person to cross
the continent of Antarctica alone and
unsupported by a resupply or a kite
Wow kite yeah I was confused about that
part too
where I was like we mean a kite but I
guess it's Hey Oh is he an Kartika he
crossed the cold if isn't a hole in or
atactic no he grasped it like that he
didn't go up to dance VFX the world is
still flat that he should have gone up
to down wanted to prove some [ __ ] well
he crossed it meaning from the
southernmost continent he crossed the
ocean to Antarctica he crossed the
actual lag guarantee Bart he went
horizontal because you literally can't
go that way
I wasn't thinking straight or flat so
yeah it's not flat thinking guys either
way either way or yeah he went in a
circle yeah yeah like that that's a long
trip man
or maybe kite just means like an
emergency vehicle or like support no the
other guy who did was flying a dragon
kite
yeah this kite in jail also means a
message that's being passed along from
cell-to-cell yeah that's a prison toggle
is it okay okay what like if I have like
let's say if someone's trying to find me
a kind they have coconut throw in a sock
and they pass it from cell-to-cell in
jail
so I was thinking kite is another word
that they're using that's not like whoa
you could be right because I didn't even
look into this whole kite thing no no no
they either I know about this guy
it was a descendant of Sir Edmund
Hillary right oh sorry I mean Hillary
the guy who who summited Everest first
was yeah no no he did that and then he
flying an Avengers cape okay Hillary was
any of that real discernment Hillary
partner okay how do you become a sir
when you're a knighted right anyway so
this guy his story
the whole reason our Stephanie home
reason why were talking about him is
because he okay 15 days after 15 days of
pulling a nearly 400 pound sled across
oh yeah yeah
Antarctica he this dude was hungry I
woulda been hungry too you woke up
during the night feeling very
overwhelmed he wanted a pizza huh and he
ended up scarfing down a shit-ton of his
bar the calling bars are 1180 calorie
bars or treated specific specifically
for him oh he ate all the food cuz he
was - he didn't ration it so he ate
about like 2,000 calories in 1 3 a.m.
binge was just 2 bars
was he smoking weed because each bars a
thousand yeah does it say it doesn't
he's like I got so high they don't occur
I [ __ ] up on my on my [ __ ] he was like
half asleep so he got the duffel bag
with his food supplies ripped it open
grabbed like chunks of these bars
stuffed him into his mouth and so like
this these bars it's a high fat mix of
coconut oil nuts dried cranberries and
cocoa powder and so yeah so then he
ended up eating too much so the next day
he woke up feeling really sick and he
also knew he had to plan ahead to ration
the food to make up for that binge [ __ ]
so when he was started when he started
picking up his campsite he felt so
uncomfortable I he was like pressing a
hand up against the fairly several times
more like a mitten probably as he was
look more like a mitten it was probably
cold here pause I mean it still his hand
oh well but you said you said hand so
hey yeah he visualized that wrong so
yeah it corrected okay that picture he's
all covered and then his hand was
thinking out my oh that's pretty cold
pint with the mitten on the men does it
have
fingers no no it's just like it's like
it's like a yeah gloves it's like I
admit no I heard that those who keep
your hands warmer than the individual
finger one but he needs to use it out in
the field you're right I mean you're not
really picking up many things I'm about
to go thankful yeah oh yes I pick up a
campsite did he did he packed up his
pancakes too did he have the little
balls on the string at the end of the
moon he might they were red they're
colored bra okay so anyway so then he
ended up he said that he tried to like
fight back the rumbling gurgles rolling
through his gut and so he ended up
thinking okay listen if I can make it to
my next destination then that's when I
can relieve myself what's the next
destination this white spot to the other
way when he shits does it come out like
a brown icicle can you imagine while
it's coming out it's freezing because
it's so cold oh god I would burn my ass
jeah Oh what if he falls on his own [ __ ]
and gets stuck to the ice like you know
when you lick a pole or some [ __ ] I
stand here for 12 hours and never
thought of that
okay so after six hours of hiking and in
nearly minus 25 degrees oh my god what
does that feel like insane - 25 never
heard I know
- 31.6 Celsius I thought we had global
warming yeah riddle me this thank you
thank you just wanted to make that point
real quick so anyway so then at that
point he he thought he could just pass
some gas to uv8 the pressure in his
stomach so he tried it but there was
more than guests that came out yeah I
wonder if he had chains of clothes there
no so and and it's soul let me tell you
so in this 54 day trek he only packed
the one pair of underwear
so he had do that you never watch it me
I want to video no there's a reason so
is because for all that amount of time
he decided to take up that wait in that
space for food and so he had 400 pounds
of just food into place yes how much
could a pair of underwear way it's one
pair just in case you [ __ ] yourself even
know weeks worth is not a pound
you know what put it in your hat yeah
[Laughter]
your hand put it in the mother [ __ ]
bin like that like I bring an extra pair
just in case that [ __ ] myself but I'm
going to like Vegas for a night you know
so relatable or Thwaites really a issue
you could pack g-strings true yes
yeah have y'all ever sharted in
g-strings
no have you no you sharted in a g-string
it just goes straight to the pants
there's nothing holding it back no what
about the whale tail part mmm-hmm
it's literally like speeding through
flies yeah this is why we need
scientists on the sharding is a guy oh
because i think most of us we sharp when
we're peeing standing up and then push
math but if you guys are clean I farted
while I keep yeah but then that your ass
is already pointing at the right here
yeah I don't feel anything come on my
butt girls do do you ever give her like
all the walls are your oh sorry ladies
do you ever brats you ever hold the wall
while your boy you're peeing peeing no
but shooting sometimes sometimes they
[ __ ] do this with their [ __ ] no kiss
yo y'all yelling you gotta hold yourself
up in public taller this hit you like
sometimes I find myself like holding the
wall
I refuse to touch bathroom walls yeah
know what you're supposed to do it you
just go like this
just shoot it out yeah pretty much
I relax you guys have never started
never ever in my lines never I don't
know what that feels you have you [ __ ]
your pants I have twice this is that
shorty
no that's [ __ ] your spirit okay so
you [ __ ] your whole pants before your
[ __ ] complete completely [ __ ] your
leggings oh my god no I was in a
business suit like oh like the hard y no
no it was like a battery wait like when
you wet dirt and it's kind of clumpy a
little bit but then it's like wet Jim
you're [ __ ] disgusting
I like how he heard news about the first
guy to cross an article just focus on
the shit's oh yeah what's that with one
pair of underwear I have no sympathy
going he had to wear the same pair of
underwear for a desert you traveling in
the future is gonna see a [ __ ] stick
stain boxers be like that scene from AEI
when they go through the icicles the
robots that are gonna go through the
icicles and they're gonna find this
[ __ ] petrified human [ __ ] inside of a
boxer true oh they're even gonna know it
[ __ ] until they dissect it and they
start experimenting funny how time makes
everything valuable like we if we found
a caveman [ __ ] would be like oh we have
like will be studying I would probably
talk to everyone about it I feel like
he's gonna regret it
he could have made sure left it there I
think so yes oven he had six more hours
through the wind and snow before he
could stop set up camp again and
properly evacuate his bowels and clean
up the inside of his pants oh that's his
father's [ __ ] every step would be
accompanied by sticky shaping Oh
doesn't you get a rash cuz I know photo
change take his diaper within like a
couple hours he gets arise he's getting
a nice wrap if I'm seeing myself on a
long-ass ship like that immediately and
plus he's probably around nobody else
right in the [ __ ] blizzard so he
probably did not just [ __ ] if you think
about it right you don't want to expose
skin to that kind of weather yeah so he
probably can't just take off his pants
he probably has to set up camp barricade
himself and [ __ ] inside the boy is a
smart assumptions but but we could but
it is dumb just set up a camp to change
your poopy underwear so we can make a
dump see damn I can't believe he ate all
those bars like in my head I feel like
he had a bag of Snickers and in a bag of
like his his giant protein bars a
thousand it was like sleeping was like a
reason for the Snickers but then grab
the other [ __ ] you know
yo Campbell Mars bars with the poopy
boys
[ __ ] [ __ ] why would he tell anyone
poor strips to look at he's wearing Pore
strips yeah that's crazy the black kids
are real yeah this is like pretty much
promoting his book I wrote a book about
but I read his book now cuz I'm like you
make very very dumb decisions how I only
brought one pair of underwear endangered
on a whole last trip bro lamer that
makes no sense
man the decision I would have dodged my
underwear and wiped my ass with snow or
made like a flag out of it froze nothing
cool kid mark [ __ ] that's why you
can't send this guy at me if you want to
discredit Flat Earth theory this who we
talking about right now his credibility
is he [ __ ] his pants and walked across
that will be Pat Scott we can't we can't
trust that guy flat earth guys are
[ __ ] laughing at us right now try
again if you're gonna discredit flat our
theory
[Music]
[Music]